Trascrizione: Antonina Santoro
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Non credete a Giancarlo,
ha detto una marea di fesserie.
Io sono un piccolo insegnante
di una piccola scuola superiore,
di una piccola città a sud di Lecce,
e vorrei essere testimone del fatto
che ognuno di noi,
non importa quanto sia grande,
quanto sia importante,
può essere fautore
e promotore di un cambiamento.
Io ad esempio, pochi mesi fa
come avete sentito,
anche se mi hanno assegnato
un premio altisonante, prestigioso
come il Global Teacher Award,
e mi hanno nominato
"Docente dell'anno" del 2020,
so per certo di non essere
una persona speciale.
So per certo che qualsiasi insegnante
potrebbe meritare questi premi,
se solo iniziasse ad avere un po'
il coraggio di pensare, e agire,
fuori dalla scatola.
Sono - ho speso un po'
degli ultimi vent'anni
a cercare di capire quali fossero
i problemi della scuola.
Ho speso vent'anni per cercare di capire
quale forma dovremmo dare
alla nostra scuola,
la scuola di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Anzi no -
quale forma di scuola i nostri ragazzi
hanno realmente bisogno.
Sono stati 20 anni
di tentativi, di insuccessi:
sono stati anni
di sconfitte, di fallimenti;
ma sono stati anche anni di grandi,
grandissime soddisfazioni e successi,
soprattutto da parte dei nostri studenti.
Dopo vent'anni, credo di aver capito.
Credo di aver capito:
e insieme ai miei colleghi,
due mesi fa abbiamo iniziato
a sperimentare
una nuova forma di scuola.
Abbiamo iniziato a sperimentare
una scuola che abbiamo chiamato
"studentecentrica".
La scuola studentecentrica, come dire,
con tutto il rispetto
e con tutte le dovute, e immense,
differenze del caso,
se il grande maestro Leonardo da Vinci
ha pensato di mettere l'uomo al centro,
noi al centro dell'universo,
noi stiamo pensando di mettere
al centro dell'universo Scuola
lo studente, gli studenti;
e voi direte: come, non c'è lo studente
al centro della scuola?
No, non c'è lo studente:
alcuni pensano che ci siano
gli insegnanti - errato.
Qualcun altro pensa che siano le materie:
anche questo è sbagliato.
Al centro, a volte, c'è l'intera classe:
ma sempre c'è il programma.
Il programma da svolgere,
come se fosse un protocollo
da marciare lungo questo percorso,
e per poi magari scoprire, ad aprile,
di essere in ritardo sul programma.
E allora acceleriamo ancora di più,
per arrivare a fine anno scolastico
e poter dire, con orgoglio:
"Ho finito il programma".
E chissenefrega se gli studenti,
se metà della classe
non è riuscita a stare al passo.
La scuola studentecentrica, invece,
cerca di mettere ogni studentessa
e ogni studente al centro,
e lo fa con due percorsi innovativi.
Il primo percorso vede noi docenti
impegnati a far salire
di gradino gli studenti
nella scala "DAIE" -
anche il nome è simpatico.
Si tratta, praticamente,
di vedere gli alunni
e farli passare da demotivati -
che in ogni classe ci sono,
gli alunni demotivati -
allo stato di attenti.
Quelli che sono nello stato di attenti,
allo stato degli interessati;
e i più bravi, quelli bravi
che sono già nello stato di interessati,
fargli fare un ulteriore passo in avanti,
in uno stato che ancora non esiste,
che è quello degli esperti,
magari con programmi di eccellenza.
E qui, qualcuno direbbe: e i voti?
Questo sistema non sostituisce i voti,
si aggiunge ai voti:
e io sono certo al cento per cento
che se noi insegnanti
ci concentriamo su questo sistema,
i voti aumenteranno da sé:
ogni gradino passato,
ogni passaggio da uno Stato all'altro
è un successo, una conquista.
Il secondo percorso
è quello di vedere la scuola
in tre forme nuove:
un atelier di stimoli;
un osservatorio di interessi;
e una palestra di crescita personale.
Mi spiego meglio:
la scuola, a partire dalla prima media
fino al quinto superiore,
potrebbe ospitare in classe
una serie di professionisti,
di esperti, di operatori nel mondo -
anzi, di tanti mondi;
dare la possibilità ai nostri ragazzi
di incontrare chi opera
nella moda, nello sport,
nella tecnologia, nelle ecosostenibilità.
E poi, il secondo passaggio:
stare attenti a vedere quando,
nei nostri alunni, si accendono gli occhi.
Se a Marta si accendono gli occhi
a sentir parlare una giornalista,
forse abbiamo scoperto un interesse;
se a Giovanni si accendono gli occhi
quando vede una stampante 3D,
forse abbiamo scoperto un interesse.
Terza fase: come una palestra,
fornire agli studenti strumenti e coach
per farli crescere in quel
particolare campo di interesse.
Io sono sicuro che, in questo modo,
gli studenti vivranno la scuola -
un'istituzione tra le più importanti
della loro adolescenza -
come una vera e propria rampa di lancio
verso il loro futuro personalizzato.
E permettetemi di dirlo,
un futuro che io immagino
in cui saranno più felici.
Noi, a dire la verità, in questi 20 anni
una forma grezza e artigianale
di scuola studentecentrica
l'abbiamo anche applicata,
attraverso l'educazione
dell'imprenditorialità.
Abbiamo incentivato - no, troppo gentile:
abbiamo costretto
i nostri alunni, dai 14 anni,
a inventarsi una microidea
imprenditoriale.
Vengono chiamate startup, oggi.
E li aiutiamo a far sì che queste idee
vadano realmente sul mercato.
Non stiamo parlando di simulazioni:
parliamo di piccole, vere, imprese.
In questi anni ne abbiamo realizzate,
coi i nostri studenti,
una cinquantina sino ad ora;
tantissime sono miseramente fallite;
alcune sono sopravvissute
per qualche anno;
altre ancora sono diventate
delle vere e proprie aziende.
Poi, ce ne sono di nuovissime
che stanno partendo in questi giorni,
e non sappiamo ancora che fine faranno.
Però, fatemi raccontare qualche storia
in modo che vi sia un po' più chiaro.
Lui è Alberto Paglialunga.
Oggi ha un po' più di trent'anni,
e ha creato un'azienda di e-commerce
dove vende arredobagno,
dove vende climatizzatori,
dove vende degli arredi.
Non mi meraviglierei che, tra di voi,
ci fosse qualche suo cliente.
Ha creato questo e-commerce
nove anni fa: si chiama Deki.
E a nove anni di distanza,
oggi l'azienda fattura
50 milioni di euro all'anno,
ha 170 dipendenti sotto i 35 anni,
200.000 clienti.
Non c'è scritto sulla slide,
ma dà lavoro a queste persone nel Salento:
non stiamo parlando,
praticamente, del Nord-Est,
non stiamo parlando di Milano:
stiamo parlando delle porte di Lecce.
Questo ragazzo ha iniziato
dal garage di casa sua -
non nella Silicon Valley, a Novoli.
E lì ho scritto, anche,
che ci sono tre premi;
ma in realtà è lo stesso premio,
vinto per tre anni,
dove viene premiato
come miglior e-commerce in Italia
per il settore arredo.
E già questa è una gran bella notizia.
Ma la vera notizia è che Alberto
ha vinto per tre anni,
ma al secondo posto
è arrivato il colosso Ikea.
Isabella, Giovanna, Benedetta,
Francesco e Samuele
hanno creato una nuova startup:
la chiamano "Gli ecoisti".
In pratica, stanno studiando metodi nuovi
per educare gli adulti
a rispettare l'ambiente,
a rispettare i beni comuni.
Ad oggi hanno ricevuto
3000 euro da sponsor,
e il progetto non è ancora partito.
Hanno, semplicemente,
creduto nelle loro idee.
Stanno lavorando al lancio
dell'aggettivo "ecoista":
se fra qualche mese, qualche anno,
vi capiterà di leggere, da qualche parte,
della "azienda ecoista dell'anno",
sappiate che quell'aggettivo
è stato creato
da alcuni alunni di una scuola superiore.
E stanno lavorando a creare 12 premi:
non a riceverli, a crearli.
Vogliono premiare, ad esempio:
le aziende ecoiste dell'anno;
il personaggio ecoista dell'anno;
la scuola ecoista dell'anno;
il sindaco ecoista dell'anno.
Poi ci sono in pratica,
questa intera classe,
il quarto superiore -
un quarto quadriennale -
che sta lavorando, praticamente,
a creare un sito
dedicato a raccontare le storie
di artigianato del territorio
di altissima qualità.
È una start up nascente,
proprio in questi giorni.
Hanno considerato 18
categorie diverse di artigiani,
e hanno trovato, scovato,
44 diversi artigiani.
E i ragazzi, adesso,
li stanno intervistando;
stanno andando presso le botteghe
per conoscere le loro storie,
per raccontarle;
e perché no, per poter vendere
i loro prodotti sulla rete.
Questa classe, invece,
nel 2016 avevano 14 anni.
Hanno creato un movimento
contro il bullismo.
Per la prima volta - e, credo,
oggi ancora unica esperienza -
di ragazzi che hanno creato un movimento
di lotta al bullismo e al cyber bullismo:
Perché prima volta?
Perché è la prima volta
che succede che lo fanno i ragazzi.
Perché sino ad oggi,
la lotta al bullismo -
e sono vent'anni che ne parliamo -
la facciamo noi adulti.
L'ha fatto il Ministero, la Polizia,
i dirigenti, docenti, psicologi;
però, se siamo ancora qui a parlarne,
probabilmente abbiamo fallito.
E allora, questi ragazzi hanno scovato
un modo per combattere
il bullismo dal basso;
hanno inventato il modello "MABASTA"
Modello MABASTA che, ad oggi,
ha raccolto 45.000 euro
dal pubblico e dal privato:
partecipano a qualsiasi genere di bando,
bussano a tutte le porte;
e sono riusciti, con quei soldi,
a portare il loro modello
in 600 classi diverse.
600 classi diverse
che hanno applicato il modello,
che hanno sperimentato
la validità del modello.
Sono stati in sedici regioni diverse:
e hanno vinto 23 premi,
in questi cinque anni,
nazionali e internazionali.
Hanno vinto l'Open Fab 2018,
di Bnp Paribas Cardiff;
hanno vinto, nel 2019,
come miglior startup studentesca d'Europa,
dove tutti i loro concorrenti
erano studenti universitari:
erano gli unici liceali!
In questo gruppo, però,
c'è una storia particolare:
quello lì al centro, lo vedete
quello è Mirko, Mirko Cazzato.
Mirko Cazzato è agli onori della cronaca
perché un mese fa è risultato
che Mirco è uno dei dieci studenti
più impattanti al mondo,
grazie al Global Student Prize.
Sembra quasi fatto apposta:
ma qualcuno di voi, probabilmente,
ieri ha visto Mirko ai "soliti ignoti",
e la sera prima a "Porta a porta",
perché è diventato, veramente,
il portabandiera italiano
dell'impegno sociale.
Lui ha vent'anni, oggi:
ma ha cinque anni alle spalle
di una bellissima Startup sociale.
Lì, un altro grande ha detto:
"Sii il cambiamento che vuoi vedere".
Allora, ci pensavo l'altro giorno:
e probabilmente, inconsciamente,
in questi anni io ho cercato
di creare, di modellare la scuola
e farla diventare come io stesso
avrei voluto frequentarla,
cioè fare la scuola
che io avrei voluto frequentare.
E questa è una cosa
che tutti possono fare:
tutti possono impegnarsi
a cercare di fare un cambiamento.
Cercare di vedere - da subito,
pensare la propria giornata:
vi svegliate il mattino; fate colazione;
uscite; andate al lavoro; andate a scuola;
passate il pranzo;
trascorrete il pomeriggio;
passate la sera; la cena; il dopocena;
di nuovo andate a letto.
In questi percorsi,
ogni qualvolta doveste trovare
un intoppo, un problema,
qualcosa che non va,
non vi lamentate.
Anzi, no, potete lamentarvi:
ma subito dopo il lamento,
cominciate ad essere propositivi,
a pensare a una soluzione
piccola, microscopica:
perché probabilmente, quella soluzione
che andrete a cercare,
quella soluzione che andrete a trovare
potrebbe essere utile
a dieci, cento, o mille altre persone.
Alcune delle più belle start up
sono nate in questo modo,
per risolvere piccoli problemi personali.
E allora tu, tu, tu,
tutti quanti voi, che siete qui
seduti davanti a me,
domani -
E attenzione - non ho detto un domani,
ho detto domani, domenica 21 novembre;
cercate anche voi di essere fautori
di un piccolo cambiamento.
Perché se vi impegnate in questo senso,
io sono sicurissimo che voi,
i vostri figli, i vostri nipoti,
troveranno un mondo più gentile,
un mondo più rispettoso,
un mondo decisamente migliore;
e avrete quella piccola,
grande soddisfazione di aver contribuito.
(Applausi)